ضمن الحالات الطبيه النادره المسجله على
مستوى العالم والاولى في الشرق الاوسط
تمكن فريق طبي السعودي من اجراء عمليه
ولاده قيصريه ناجحه لمريضه تعيش على مضخه
الصناعيه مساعده للقلب الاطباء في مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي ومركز الابحاث طمئنوا
اهل المريضه بانها اصبحت والمولود بصحه
جيده كانت الام تعاني من ضعف شديد في عضله
القلب استدعى زراعه مضخه الصناعيه مساعده
وبعد اكتشاف الحمل احيلت الى تخصص الرياض
لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه بعدها تم تحديد موعد
مبكر للولاده القيصريه التي اجريت في
الاسبوع الثاني والثلاثين من الحمل لتنقل
بعدها الى الجناح القلب بالمستشفى لحين
توفر متبرع مناسب لزراعه قلب لها
[موسيقى]
من الرياض ينضم الينا استشار امراض وزراعه
القلب والمشرف العام لحاله الام الصحيه
والدكتور جهاد البريكي دكتور يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك معنا شكرا على تواجدك معنا في
صباح العربيه
صباح الخير وشكرا على الاستضافه طيب دكتور
لاول مره في المنطقه عمليه ولاده ناجحه
لام تضع مضخه قلب اصطناعيه حدثنا اولا عنك
عن تحدي عن هذه العمليه وخطورتها
في بدايه البرنامج هذه المريض اجريت لها
زراعه
مضخه صناعيه مساعده القلب تمهيدا او الى
حين توفر متبرع مناسب لزراعه القلب هذول
المرضى بدي استمروا بتلقي علاجات
ومن ضمنها الدوله المسين للدم لتجنب حدوث
تخثرات داخل المضخه اضافه الى هذا يحتاج
الى متابعه دائما للتاكد من سلامه المريض
وسلامه عمل المضخم في حاله حدوث الحمل
الاضافه للتغيرات الفيزيولوجيه اللي ممكن
صاحب الحمل واللي تحتاج الى تعديل في عمل
المضخه هناك ثلاثه امور اللي ممكن تحصل في
اثناء الحمل واللي تشكل خطوره على حياه
الام والجنين
الامر الاول هناك احتمال انه يحصل ارتفاع
في ضغط الدم
واللي ممكن يشكل خطوره على الام وممكن
اكثر على العمل مضخه الالتهابات الامر
الثالث ايضا يحتاج الى متابعه ايضا لتربيه
المشيمه والجدين
لانه نقص الترويه ممكن ياثر على حياه
الجنين الامر الرابع ايضا هناك محتاج الى
هناك حاجه لمتابعه ادويه السيوله لانه
اضطرابات ممكن تؤدي الى نزيف او ممكن لا
سمح الله يحصل خسرات تؤثر على العمل
المضخه وتشكل خطوره على حياه الام طيب
دكتور جهاد ما اكثر ما كان يقلقهم في
العمليه يعني خصوصا انه اذا ما قررناها مع
الولاده الطبيعيه في مجهود كبير وضخلي
الدم في الجسم بشكل كبير الولاده القيصريه
نتحدث عن بنج هل هذا كان يشكل مثلا مشكله
رئيسيه لان يتضرر القلب اللي مستعمل اصلا
بمضخه
طبعا لما لما احنا عرفنا عن
مبلغنا بحدوث الحمل
ادخلت المريضه الى المستشفى
وتم تقييمها من قبل فريق من عده تخصصات
واضافه الى تقييم وتعديل عمل المضخه
لتتناسب مع احتياجات الام
من ضمن الفريق المتخصص كان في تخصصات
مختلفه من ضمنها استشاري التقدير
الاستشاريه اللي هي النساء والولاده
واستشاري القلب اضافه الى خاصات اخرى
وعمل تقييم كامل وبعدها تم تحديد موعد
الولاده
ونوعيه ومكان الولاده
فيعني طبعا هذه الاشياء تحتاج الى رعايه
خاصه
ومتابعه مكثفه للتاكد من عدم حدوث اي خلل
او مضاعفات ممكن تشكل خطوره على حاله الام
دكتور الحمل استمرت 32 اسبوعا والام
الحامل بمضخه قلب الصناعيه الم تخشوا من
حصول المضاعفات هل حصلت اي مضاعفات خطيره
على الام او الجنين او هل يعني حصل اي
اضطرابات على عمل المضخه خلال فتره الحمل
في الواقع هي زي ما قلت لك في البدايه انه
في اول ما ادخلت الى المستشفى تم بعض
التعديلات على وظيفه المضخه
لتتناسب مع احتياجات الام كانت هناك ايضا
متابعه مستمره لحاله المريضه من قبل
الفريق للتاكد انه ما حصل اي وما حصل
الحمد لله اي ارتفاعات في ضغط الدم اللي
احتاجت الى اي تدخل او
امور اخرى كان حصل بعض الالتهابات وعولجت
والحمد لله يعني
تمت الامور بسلام دكتور جهاد مشكوره
جهودكم وكل فريق العمل الذي اشرف على هذه
العمليه وهذه الامراه هذه السيده كانت
تبحث عن قلبها في هذه الدنيا واستعانت
بمضخه قلب الصناعيه ولكنها رزقت بقلبها من
جديد نحن نشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور جهاد
البريكي المشرف العملي حاله الام الصحيه
واستشاري امراض وزراعه القلب من الرياض
شكرا لك